boys
we are not boys colonel yeah we
aren't boys at all wait what's a
boy any well well well if it isn't
my piece of son talking about
boys you mom and his
handsome friend Vinny
hey mrs. pepper snacks how are you moist
and not just cuz I'm packed in water
honey
cuz I'm honey for dick mom I've been
thinking about that boy comment
Vinny
just let it go Colonel there's nothing
we can do well I did some creepy
internet stuff and found out where Timmy
pop goes to school really yeah I also
found out his sister has lupus okay I
don't see how that's relevant
it might come up any I highly doubt that
hey Timmy pop I heard your sister has
lupus who the are you guys you
called us boys on the Internet
move aside Vinny I'm about to stab a
child hey what's going on here you're
some of the biggest boys I've ever
seen have you considered fbb see Vinny I
think this guy wants us to watch porn no
boy behavioral Center it's a place
where boys like you can go and
learn how to well how to unfuck
yourselves here take some literature a
rehab center for recovering boys
seems sketchy and made-up
[Music]
hello boys I'm dr. D'Angelo head of the
FBC I found in the center in honor of my
late wife and I've been helping cure
boys like you ever since we are not
boys dude well if you're so sure
that you want boys just step on the
scale all that proves is anywhere flood
boys I'm going to recommend or intensive
boy rehab program and you think
that'll cure us it's a risky operation
but it's a risk I'm willing to take now
let's move along
so much fuckery so little time next I'm
going to ask you fuckwads a few
questions try to answer them honestly
where are these wires for this machine
gauges your answers and you in the
ass should you answer like a
boy you wait seriously
no not really it just sucks you should
you answer like a boy now first
question a girl gives you her number
what do you do take pictures hmm not
surprising dictor's are the lifeblood of
the boy now moving on to question 2
your boy asks you if you would like to
throw down upon some cocaine what do you
say tell him I probably won't do any and
then ask for tiny key bumps all night
until the coast guard
oh holy the boy is strong in
you two now finally what do you think of
this fashion
Oh disgusting hey Colonel there's
something seriously up going on
here we should go check it out the pills
are working Vinnie I can feel the
fuck-boy it's leaving my body oh no dude
you're literally pooping on the floor
uh-uh damn those pills that you took
earlier from that nurse that I also took
but I spit them out because I'm
skeptical of all this interesting
[Music]
this machine doesn't gauge answers that
bastard doctor just shocks whoever he
wants to make them think their boys
[Music]
ketamine damn it I knew it colonel
you gotta wake up I was right this whole
place is a scam boys aren't even a
real thing oh yes they are and you're
the biggest boy of them all Vinnie
why are you doing this because a
boy stole my wife I thought your wife
was dead well she's dead to me
when I went away to medical school it
was hard for my wife and I to
communicate so I suggested we get
snapchat snapchat no one communicates on
snapchat dude they just send pictures of
their like pussies and dicks and tits
and if only I had known that back
then it only took a day before my wife's
phone was flooded with she left me
and ever since I've dedicated my life to
ridding the world of boys like you
Jesus
you're insane I'm not insane I'm a
doctor no don't you see you've become
everything you hate what you've been
blaming boys for your problems when
the truth has been right under your
noses all time your wife's just at home
and you can't blame the player if you
don't play the game my god you're right
how could I have been so blind perhaps I
was wrong about you - you are not
boys yeah we're man
no don't you see the real problem here
is that we're all too obsessed with
labels doctor boy skanky ass ho
it's all the same just labels buying
into labels and hiding behind titles as
an identity only gives more power to
those who wish to divide us I think what
we really need to do here is focus on
the one label that unites us
people were all just people that was
beautiful you two should go spread your
message be the change that you want to
see
[Music]
goddammit